hey this is presh to Walker
ABCD is a rectangle that's made up of
five different rectangles that are
congruent to each other as shown
suppose the length of a d is equal to
10.
construct the triangle Abe where e is
along the side CD
the question is what is the area of
triangle Abe
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this is a delightful question because at
first there seems there is not enough
information
let's work it out carefully
suppose the vertical length is equal to
l and suppose the horizontal distance of
this rectangle is equal to w
because the five rectangles are
congruent to each other we can label the
dimensions of the other rectangles so
here we have W here we have another W
here we have L and here we have another
l
now focus on the side a b
one length is equal to l but the other
length is also equal to 2W so we have 2W
is equal to l
now from the length of a d we have that
2L plus W is equal to 10. we can
substitute that L is equal to 2W and
then we can simplify this equation to
solve that W is equal to 2. then 2W is
equal to l is equal to 4. so we're
almost ready to solve the problem
the length of a b is equal to four so
now what's the area of the triangle Abe
we know that its height upon the base of
4 is equal to 10.
so the area is equal to 4 times 10
divided by 2 which is equal to 20 square
units and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign